Hello Freak bitches.
A video game was pretty intense
to the new UFC game on ps a.
And I know it sounds
like I'm plugging but it,
no,
it was cool.
We would yelling me and my
me and my friend like God,
like it was that intense cause it was,
you know,
there's parts where you almost about to
knock the guy out and then it's a good
game.
It's a very good game.
I have fun so I can
attest to it because uh,
I had to do the commentary for that game.
Yeah.
Like the,
when you hear that EA sports game,
that's not commentary from actual fights.
Right.
That's commentary.
Just me doing pretend and
Goldberg don't pretend.
And Dude,
we did a fuck load of hours.
I mean it was hours and hours and hours
and hours and it was a over a long,
and I'm not complaining,
I'm just saying you got to the
APP stuff and there's main man.
What scan?
Oh
Yay.
Yeah,
I'm in the game.
You have to um,
have a secret.
I got to have a code like the Konami Code.
Oh,
I did this.
So I can get out of doing more commentary
because there was so much to do.
Tim,
I wish I looked that good.
There was so much to do,
uh,
as though it was,
it was a constant grind,
but I put my app,
my full effort into it.
Like I really wanted it to be good.
Oh,
I was thinking if I was a kid
and I was playing this game,
I would want it to sound like,
like a guy really got head killed.
It's,
it's intense man.
Like we are here.
It is,
man.
It,
it was,
it was a fun.
It was like,
I want to see me get beat the fuck up.
Just Jamie.
Jamie shown a video of me about
to get my ass kicked by Nick Diaz.
How you get destroyed
really fast with a mansion.
If the game's realistic,
pull it up.
Come on,
Hajj.
And I get fucked up
people who want to see it.
But they might have used to
show you a secret character.
They might have.
You got some bullshit skills.
Might have you juiced up.
I got,
it.
Doesn't matter.
I got some bullshit with pills.
Let's hear Mike,
cause you know what,
I'm super casual fans.
So my commentary,
no bra with the leg kick.
I've never heard this before.
Oh it wasn't?
Oh Broga.
Good with the leg kicks.
Row Rogan got kicked in the face.
Oh good.
With the kicks.
Diaz is backing it up.
Rogan missed.
Oh really?
Kicked in the chest.
Tattoos.
Accurate.
Look at that.
Holy Shit.
Oh,
oh.
Oh Rob isn't that can about
the high disadvantage.
Oh Oh oh.
[inaudible] is in danger.
Let's see what Rogan's
ground game is like.
Not Good.
Diaz is about the
dark shit off my back.
Will Rogen be able to pull off
a submission from this position.
Oh rogue is it?
Oh,
let them turn around.
It's called a sweep this amount.
Oh Man,
I let him up.
Wow.
Good kid.
Roll it back up.
Oh ooh.
This should be illegal.
Oh,
rolled it should be illegal back.
And two people fake fight when you know
one dude would beat the fuck out of me.
I said may so did not leave
any and he gives the illusion.
Oh this is so stupid
staff.
He's out.
Oh Shit.
Oh wait,
why are they let me punch him in
the head when he was unconscious?
Why don't they stop the fight quick and
that does fake me rather than the fake
ham.
How'd that feel?
Weird,
but felt weird.
You know what bothered me the most?
The last two punches?
Because it wasn't,
he was already unconscious.
The fake him.
Gotcha.
Oh,
did you know how hard Nick
Diaz would fuck me up?
Like this is an embarrassment to humanity.
This is allowed to be
a visual image of me.
Beaten Nick Diaz his ass.
I've dumped all the brown James before.
I do enjoy shit,
man.
That's what,
that's what?
it's an escape.
Okay.